[Música]
la electricidad es un mundo fascinante
porque está en todo lo que nos rodea
para que pueda ver por ejemplo una
reacción química se requiere
electricidad los colores que vemos en un
arcoiris se deben a un fenómeno
eléctrico
ahorita mi movimiento que estoy haciendo
es gracias a la electricidad que llega
mismo oscuros
el cerebro el cerebro siempre siempre
está generando electricidad y gracias a
esto podemos pensar y en este contexto
del pensar pues imaginemos que estamos
en casa y queremos iluminar cierto
espacio entonces vamos y activamos
verdad un interruptor eléctrico y hay
una circulación de corriente esa
corriente llega a lo que denominamos en
méjico un foco y tenemos luz
incandescente y podemos iluminar un
espacio de igual manera para satisfacer
cierta necesidad pues podemos accionar
otro interruptor para
proveer de electricidad algún aparato
electrodoméstico y aquí cabe la pregunta
de dónde viene la electricidad
alguna vez se lo han preguntado
bien entonces si queremos responder esta
respuesta empezamos a inspeccionar
nuestra casa y vemos que en la casa hay
una red eléctrica y esa red eléctrica a
su vez se está conectando a otra red
eléctrica que pasa a través de nuestra
calle y a la cual está conectado la casa
del vecino y a la cual está conectado el
vecindario y ese vecindario a través de
una red eléctrica se conecta con otro
vecindario y así sucesivamente hay toda
una interconexión eléctrica que va a
proveer de electricidad a una ciudad y a
través de una red eléctrica de mayor
potencia se provee electricidad a otras
ciudades y así sucesivamente hasta que
hasta tener todo un sistema
interconectado eléctrico en un país
y este país a su vez puede estar
interconectado con otro país
eléctricamente por ejemplo en el caso de
méxico en nuestra frontera norte en
estábamos conectados con eeuu de
norteamérica
en el lado sur estamos interconectados
con guatemala y estamos interconectados
con belice y con esos países tenemos
intercambio energético
y entonces cuando ya vemos todo este
conjunto de interconexiones pues esto se
podría ver como una telaraña todo bien
complejo y obviamente esta complejidad
también
existe en el contexto operativo de las
redes eléctricas y porque en el contexto
operativo porque se debe de cumplir un
postulado físico la energía no se crea
ni se destruye sólo se transforma en un
contexto de esta interacción eléctrica
esto lo que nos dice es que la demanda
de energía que tenemos debe de ser igual
a la generación de energía siempre debe
de ser igual y entonces qué es lo que
pasa en esta complejidad operativa
incrementamos la demanda de energía
eléctrica tenemos que incrementar la
demanda la generación de energía esto
para que para que se siga cumpliendo el
balance es tener en demanda de energía
eléctrica se reduce tenemos que reducir
esa generación de energía eléctrica para
que para que haya ese balance existe ese
balance y esa es la complejidad de la
operación de los sistemas eléctricos
porque no tenemos los otros
conocimientos de cómo esta demanda de
energía eléctrica va a estar cambiando y
entonces cómo le vamos a dar seguimiento
con esta generación de energía eléctrica
ese es el problema
en este contexto que es lo que se ha
hecho bueno pues al igual que se
pronostica el tiempo que nosotros lo
podemos ver en los noticieros que nos
dicen a tal hora va a llover o va a
haber cierta irradiación solar
o va a haber cierta temperatura al igual
que hacen los sistemas eléctricos ahí
pronosticamos cuál va a ser la demanda
de energía eléctrica para los próximos
15 minutos para la próxima media hora
para los próximos 45 minutos y para la
próxima hora y eso qué es lo que permite
en los operadores de un sistema
eléctrico puedan hacer las acciones de
control para tener lista la generación
de energía eléctrica y satisfacer esa
demanda y bien con los avances de
técnicas matemáticas de técnicas de
pronóstico de demanda
de comunicaciones y cuestiones
electrónicas todo este seguimiento de la
demanda de energía eléctrica se ha ido
automatizando y esto que nos lleva a los
sistemas eléctricos inteligentes
hacia allá va el futuro de las redes
eléctricas en la cual podamos
automatizar esa satisfacción de la
demanda de energía eléctrica que tenemos
todos como consumidores
aunado a la anterior todos estos avances
tecnológicos han facilitado también la
integración de las energías renovables
en particular la integración de
generadores eólicos en particular la
integración de plantas fotovoltaicas eso
para que para satisfacer la demanda de
energía eléctrica pero aquí hay un nuevo
reto cuál es el reto que tanto las
plantas eólicas como las plantas
fotovoltaicas su generación de energía
eléctrica tiene una naturaleza aleatoria
y tiene una naturaleza aleatoria porque
la energía primaria que se utiliza para
ser reconvertida en el gen en energía
eléctrica depende de cuestiones
climatológicas ustedes imaginen un panel
solar entonces tiene cierta irradiación
solar y esa radiación solar la
convertimos a electricidad pero el nivel
de radiación solar va a depender de
cuestiones meteorológicas puede pasar
una nube la irradiación solar es menor y
generamos menor e electricidad
igual en las eólicas hay cierta
velocidad de viento pero si esa
velocidad de viento está variando la
potencia que estamos generando la
potencia eléctrica también está variando
y esas variaciones afectan la manera en
que podemos satisfacer la demanda de
energía eléctrica y lograr ese balance y
entonces cómo es que hacemos esa
compensación de la variación de las
energías renovables pues imaginemos que
aquí yo tengo en esta balanza la
cantidad de energía renovable que está
variando y entonces estas variaciones yo
las voy a compensar con generadores
sobre los cuales tengo control que
dependen de que de energía fósil
carbón gas bueno tal vez hidro que
podría hacer que se considera como
renovable verdad o energía limpia y con
base a estar variando esta generación
esta naturaleza aleatoria de las fuentes
renovables la compensa y eso que me da
como resultado de nuevo que yo pueda
lograr siempre ese balance energético de
demanda de energía eléctrica y
generación de energía eléctrica
pero entonces aquí cabe la pregunta
desde un punto de vista de consumo de
energía eléctrica
somos verdes
somos sustentables la respuesta en este
momento es no
porque necesitamos energía fósil para
compensar esa naturaleza aleatoria de
las fuentes renovables
esto también ustedes lo pueden ver a
nivel residencial uno puede pasar este
tal vez en algún vecindario y ve que
muchas casas tienen en sus techos verdad
paneles solares
y aquí la pregunta es este quienes viven
en esa casa
están consumiendo la energía generada
por esos paneles solares
y la respuesta es no
en sus paneles solares lo que hacen es
inyectar su cantidad de energía que
generan a la red eléctrica de
distribución y la red eléctrica nos está
regresando la energía que nosotros
requerimos y como nosotros requerimos en
la calidad que lo requerimos
entonces en este momento tampoco somos
sustentables a nivel residencial
la pregunta es podríamos ser
y la respuesta es sí
pero esto tiene un costo económico por
ejemplo ustedes podrían utilizar
solamente paneles solares y tener
baterías tener baterías y con esas
baterías estar tratando de compensar
esas variaciones
y que tienen por las plantas juego en
este caso por los paneles solares y
cuando es de noche pues obviamente
ustedes consumirían la energía que les
va a proveer todo ese conjunto de
baterías pero eso actualmente es bien
costosa
pero bueno hacia allá va y hay maneras
de hacerlo y esas maneras de hacerlo
pues lo veremos en otra plática de esta
naturaleza